chers habitants de dead x vous avez bien
en face de vous un pirate
mais ne vous inquiétez pas je ne vous
veux aucun mal bien au contraire j'ai
débarqué sur votre île pour vous parler
de ma vie de mon voyage de comment ma
vie s'est construite ou plutôt de
comment je les construite
pourquoi le pirate est bien celle
aventure la liberté la curiosité j'ai
trouvé le pirate qui est en moi
quand j'étais petit je suis tombé
amoureux des sons et de l'harmonie que
produisent ces sons entre eux et des
instruments khemed cesson je veux parler
de la musique et plus précisément j'ai
eu cette attirance pour celui qui
organise ces sons dans la musique avec
son corps ses bras ses mains et ses
doigts le chef d'orchestre
ne me demandez pas pourquoi ou comment
j'en sais rien à 5 ans j'ai eu cette
passion pour l'art de la musique et de
la direction d'orchestre et depuis je
vole vers ce trésor et ce rêve du
partage quand je serai grand je serai
chef d'orchestre
dans un premier temps je me suis dit le
chef d'orchestre c'est celui qui doit
être capable de jouer tous les
instruments alors en avant sur une
quinzaine d'années j'explorais pas loin
d'une dizaine d'instruments évidemment
avec tout ce que cela implique
c'est à dire rigueur de travail
journalière mannesman concessions et de
sacrifices pour se donner corps et âme
dans sa passion à 13 ans je décide de
quitter mon cocon familial afin que mes
études soit aménagée avec les études
musicales
ce sont des années plutôt difficile
surtout moralement mais j'avance dans
mon rêve
j'étudie maintenant l'analyse des
partitions la composition l'histoire de
la musique
et bientôt la direction d'orchestre à 17
ans et je le sens j'en suis convaincu
c'est bien ce que l'on voit la vie
écouter les sons modeler la matière
sonore fédérer un ensemble de musiciens
pour au bout du compte offrir du plaisir
et rendre cette musique accessible aussi
bien dans des milieux défavorisés que
dans des salles prestigieuses
je continue à organiser mon travail a
ciblé mon objectif tout en me laissant
les aussi aux différentes opportunités
du moment comme celle par exemple d'un
jour de remplacer le trompettiste du
groupe de reggae de mon frère
je découvre la scène et je dois dire que
cela me plaît bien je décide donc de
terminer mes études par correspondance
pour me consacrer au reggae cela dure
quatre ans vous allez peut-être me dire
on s'éloigne un peu du chef d'orchestre
chercher le point commun entre bob
marley et karajan mais si il y en a bien
un la scène le partage avec le public
et puis avec le recul cette découverte
de la scène reggae est peut-être la
meilleure chose qui me soit arrivée dans
mon développement artistique
attention je ne parle ici que de la
partie musicale je m'abstiendrai
aujourd'hui de parler de tout ce qui
entoure le reggae est ce qu'il ya du
monde au côté vix
je débarque sur cet îlot et j'y découvre
habitants du têt aide x-ray joue moins
0,2 et palissandre j pause mais sont mes
hanches manquèrent sur terre du têt
oui le conservatoire de paris
et comme on le sait tous ici
la musique c'est pas gratuit alors pour
financer mes instruments je décide de
prendre le chemin des petits boulots
tels que livret la farine tôt le matin
au boulanger ou encore travailler dans
les usines d'abattoirs ou charger les
camions frigorifiques à l'aide de
transpalettes j'ai réussi à avoir mon
permis cariste
mais toutes ces expériences ont vraiment
forget je suis tellement heureux
je vais recevoir l'enseignement de la
part de grands musiciens et surtout je
vais mettre maintenant à pied dans l'
orchestre symphonique professionnel est
là j'écoute j'entends j'apprends
j'observe et j'analyse le chef
d'orchestre en plein coeur de l'
orchestre symphonique
je commence à comprendre comment
fonctionne cet équipage que sont les
musiciens
cette grosse machine comment le chef s'y
prend pour la diriger la guider et même
parfois la faire chavirer
je suis à l'intérieur du groupe de
musiciens que je souhaite par la suite
moi-même dirigez vous imaginez quelle
chance je vois ce que les musiciens
attendent de leur chef en fait on était
en train de me donner la clé de ce
métier
la communication mais j'y reviendrai un
peu plus tard cette même période dans ma
vie j'ai tout de même un sentiment de
déséquilibres comme s'il me manquait une
certaine liberté
j'ai besoin de créer de m'évader de tous
ces codes propres monde de la musique
classique pour me rapprocher en quelque
sorte de ma période reggae respirer
l'énergie du public de manière plus
intime
plus personnel j'ai ressenti chez des
musiciens une routine ce qui m'a effrayé
d'un côté et m'a questionné et pourquoi
je ne mets chaprais pas de cet orchestre
que j'aime tant pour partir à la
recherche de nouveaux sons et de
nouvelles sensations
le pirate qui est en moi et qui
sommeille depuis mon enfance ma pelle à
l'abordage alors là tout ce qui au plus
profond de moi même
surgit telle une vague une lame
j'écris je compose je m'évade sans me
soucier du regard des autres
j'imagine ma propre histoire et prend le
large avec comme nouveau compagnon la
danse le théâtre la peinture la lumière
mordicus le pirate n'en démordra pas
d'ailleurs à cette même période
j'écris un spectacle de pirate pour les
enfants comme quoi et le petit
instrument que vous voyez là bas je les
appelais le ou nitoo c'est mon trésor
c'est une vraie joie d'une vraie liberté
je rencontre des artistes voyage et
travaille de plus en plus certes je
m'éloigne un peu de l'orchestré
symphonique mais je sais que j'y
reviendrai avec des idées de l'espoir
est encore plus de passion ça sert à
quoi
un chef d'orchestre ça c'est une grande
question
vous n'imaginez pas le nombre de
personnes qui me demandent quel est le
rôle de ce petit homme face à l'
orchestre il ya plusieurs paramètres à
comprendre et à savoir avant de
s'intéresser au chef d'orchestre en
lui-même déjà qu'ils sont tous ces
musiciens avec autant d'instruments
j'ai envie de vous répondre simplement
c'est un groupe de personnes qui a
travaillé extrêmement dur pour arriver à
l'intérieur de l'orchestré symphonique
et une idée importante par rapport au
chef d'orchestre
ce leader d'un groupe doit être capable
de s'adresser et de s'adapter aux
différentes personnes avec qui ils
souhaitent partager un moment de
communion comme par exemple ici le
concert ce qui demande d'avoir une
certaine connaissance du groupe
d'individus qu'on a en face de soi tant
l'homme seul que l'homme avec son
instrument
et maintenant imaginez vous un orchestre
symphonique devant les cordes violon
alto violoncelle contrebasse
c'est le groupe qui réunit le plus de
personnes en général entre 20 et 60
ils sont plusieurs à jouer la même
partition
ce ne sont pas des solistes du coup il
faut réussir à les intéresser
individuellement que chacun se sente
concerné par la partition jouée les
cordes attentes du chef qu'on leur
laisse le temps de jouer il faut dégager
une certaine souplesse
derrière les cordes les bois flûtes
hautbois clarinettes bassons qui eux
sont des solistes à prendre avec
délicatesse
ils ont ce côté raffiné des artisans ils
attendent du chef des gestes clairs et
précis ils sont en général entre 8 et 16
derrière les bois les cuivres trompette
cor trombone tuba
alors il peut y avoir deux cuivres et
après ça dépend vraiment du répertoire 4
6 8 10 12 14 16
ça peut monter très haut les cuivres
sont très puissants et ils souhaitent
avoir de vente eu un chef avec de
l'aplomb et surtout que le chef respire
avec eux derrière les cuivres les
percussions
les plus hauts fonds alors qu'istres ils
ont un tout autre rapport avec le chef
d'orchestre
car ce sont les plus éloignés de plus
ils jouent debout comme le chef
d'orchestre il peut y avoir un
percussionniste deux percussionnistes et
ça peut monter jusqu'à sept ou huit tout
dépend encore du répertoire de l'époque
contrairement aux cordes les
percussionnistes ne joue pas tout le
temps du coup il faut savoir
s'intéresser à eux même s'ils n'ont
qu'une note a joué pendant la soirée
j'avais tous à l'esprit ce célèbre
joueur de triangle
oui il va jouer sa note de la soirée
mais entre nous je vous dit j'aimerais
pas forcément être à sa place parce que
si le manque son coup
et rendent chez lui un peu démoralisés
vous voyez un orchestre symphonique
c'est une vraie famille avec des
personnalités très différentes à
l'intérieur
évidemment ils sont tous ici pour jouer
ensemble et en harmonie et le chef doit
être capable de tirer le meilleur de
chacun tout en fédérant l'ensemble mais
je vais vous avouer quelque chose un
orchestre symphonique peut jouer sans
chef
oui là on s'en prend un coup sur la tête
comme m il y a trois catégories de chef
d'orchestre
la première catégorie le chef
d'orchestre qui dérange l'orchestré vous
savez des fois on en voit comme ça ils
font des grands gestes
c'est pas trop ce qu'ils font
l'impression qui bat une sorte de
mayonnaise artificielle et là pour le
coup
l'orchestré symphonique joue tout seul
la deuxième catégorie de chef
d'orchestre
celui qui ne dérange pas d'orchestre oui
c'est très bien c'est magnifique où il
continue et quels sont ces bourgs je
vous suis allé si je vous suis re et la
troisième catégorie de chef d'orchestre
celui qui va apporter alors qu'istres
celui qui va avoir des idées pertinentes
qui va voir un rapport d' écoute actifs
et subtile il est dans l'adaptation de
l'autre déjà quand vous trouvez dans la
catégorie qui ne dérange pas c'est
plutôt bon signe
mais un bon chef d'orchestre c'est celui
qui va connaître extrêmement bien sa
partition
celui qui va savoir transmettre
l'interprétation qu'il a dans la tête
par le biais des gestes et de son aura
c'est celui qui va savoir écouter avant
de donner des ordres
celui qui va savoir s'adapter être juste
et convaincant dans ses prises de parole
et oui chef d'orchestre c'est un métier
et quand vous avez un chef qui se livre
face à un orchestre
alors là c'est une vraie transe
c'est une vraie passion c'est une vraie
magie c'est un partage sans mots ou les
sons les ges ne font plus qu'un j'aime
bien cette idée de télépathie entre un
chef et ses musiciens d'orchestre
maintenant que vous en savez un peu plus
sur le chef d'orchestre l'orchestré
symphonique
pensez vous qu'un pirate puisse
débarquer à la tête d'un tel navire
nous sommes confrontés six à deux mondes
complètement bien différent avec ce que
peut dégager l'image d'un pirate voyous
hors la loi flibustiers et l'aventurier
grâce aux pirates que j'ai trouvé en moi
je suis devenu le chef d'orchestre que
je suis aujourd'hui
mais alors ce n'est pas la vente sûrs
que d'être chef c'est la curiosité la
folie frôlé l'insolence avec des
partitions déjà tant jouer se libérer du
conservatisme animé chez tous ces
artistes laventure que peut-être un
concert cultiver son rêve d'enfance tout
en restant éveillé aux appels du pirate
qui sommeille en nous en fait c'était ni
plus ni moins resté un grand enfant
je crois que pour atteindre un objectif
son objectif il y a plusieurs routes
possibles
tout dépend vers quel courant se laisse
dériver même s'il semble aux antipodes
j'avais au fond de moi même ce rêve de
devenir chef d'orchestre et
parallèlement ce pirate qu'on a tous en
soi j'en suis convaincu
s'est réveillée alors est ce qu'il ne
serait pas temps maintenant d'imaginer
une histoire où les codes de la
piraterie de l'académisme s'entremêlent
ray pour donner et éveiller en vous le
pirate qui sommeille merci